here's what would happen if there were  life after death  according to a 2013 study 72 percent of  Americans believe in an afterlife if we  could prove that something else was  waiting for us after we leave our bodies  Our perceptions of this life micro dim  if we knew there were something more  profound waiting for us some people  might not wait for their lives to end  naturally to claim an eternal reward but  the end of our Lives might not be a  spiritual experience at all instead of  seeing a white light you might see ones  and zeros the director of engineering at  Google predicts that we could upload  digital copies of our brains online your  life and personality could live on in  the computers of tomorrow if your  Consciousness was uploaded into a cloud  your mind would live on for as long as  the server lasts so